hey guys
so White House down hit the theaters
this past weekend or as I like to call
it Olympus has fallen again and
surprisingly not as fun that got me
thinking about movie and TV presidents
so we've assembled a panel to help us
figure out who's the greatest movie TV
president ever
you know from Whitest Kids u know and
his new album drunk text to myself as
available on iTunes Trevor Moore hello
from the Jordan Jessie go podcast the
funniest guy in podcasting Jordan Morris
and from comedy bang bang he was George
W Bush in Harold and Kumar escape from
Guantanamo James Adomian so we kind of
broke down a bracket of the top eight
presidents get ready to zing us on this
if you think we left one out let's
introduce some pairings and decide which
and each pairing will move on
first from idiocracy president Dwayne
Elizondo Mountain Dew Herbert Camacho
versus present Lindberg from The Fifth
Element I liked Camacho because he was a
former wrestler and a porn star and now
he's president you know I'll make a case
for Tommy tiny Lister in the Fifth
Element if you watch that movie his
expression is always kind of annoyed
he's a consistent man so who do we vote
for Mountain Dew Lister come on -
Camacho it is okay round two a couple of
lighter hearted American presidents
Kevin Kline Dave Kovac from Dave versus
Andrew Shepherd Michael Douglas from the
American president Trevor any thoughts
on Dave versus the American president uh
I'm gonna go Dave
it's a light-hearted romp about the
executive branch pulling off a major
fraud to the American people but it's
fun I got to go with Dave as well so
kevin kline moving on made it to the
mount rushmore our next matchup I paired
a movie president against a great TV
President David Palmer from 24 vs. Air
Force Ones James Marshall Harrison Ford
Wow
I'm gonna go Harrison Ford because what
I love about the Air Force one movie is
that if you squint your eyes and you
kind of pretend you can imagine that
it's still a Jack Ryan character
a few years before it was like how dare
you come in and bark at me like some dog
how dare you come in here and lecture I
dare you sir how dare you come into this
office and bark at me like some little
junkyard dog I am the President of the
United States and then he beat him in
the next election and now he's president
yes Harrison Ford he has more agency as
a president he's punching the guy and
throwing him off the airplane oh yeah
takes matters into his own hands it's
totally not true like presidents don't
do that get off my plane I will say this
ari the catchphrase get off my plane I
think it's kind of a bad catchphrase I
know I voted for Harrison Ford but he's
just saying what he wants the guy to do
yeah second worst
Harrison Ford catchphrase behind
regarding Henry's Ritz crackers hahaha
Ritz
get this man some Ritz crackers ha ha ha
finally we have Josiah Bartlett from the
West Wing Martin Sheen against Thomas
Whitmore Independence Day Bill Pullman
not go Paxton I just think that Martin
Sheen doesn't get it cuz it's just such
a horse president like you know it's
such a good guy
surely we can do it again as we did in a
time when our eyes look towards the
heavens and with outstretched fingers
we touched the face of God he's just too
utopian so uh we gotta go we gotta go
with another damn cowboy combat along in
the air so we've established our Mount
Rushmore president Camacho Dave Harrison
Ford and Bill Pullman first the
semifinal round of rolla president
bracket here Harrison Ford James
Marshall Air Force One vs. Kevin Kline
Dave I think Harrison Ford stuff has to
win by default he actually got elected
he was the will he got elected but and
Kevin Kline never did a fourth Indiana
Jones that's true are we taking away are
we taking away points for Harrison Ford
just because of his bad choice
absolutely in spite of crystal skull
Harrison Ford is the choice here so he
moves on to the finals okay now oh man
this is a barn burner
Thomas Whitmore Bill Pullman from
independence day against president
Camacho Terry Crews idiocracy I think
it's about time for a black president to
move ahead in this in this bracket yeah
I'm probably going Camacho here too I
like the fact that he used to be a porn
star and I think we can all agree that
we would probably trust a president more
if we had seen his dog I'm gonna go Bill
Pullman Bill Pullman saved us from damn
aliens
I just think Camacho is too awesome to
be deny Camacho's going on our final two
Terry Crews vs. Harrison Ford I hear so
here point four Harrison Ford is then he
killed Gary Oldman who is arguably the
greatest movie villain of all time
he's han Solo he's Indiana Jones he's
Billy Blade Runner a William William
Boyd Runner sorry
he is iconic he's the best of iconic
character I'd vote for all three of
those characters for being president
guys let's vote for president I'm gonna
go third party and go Peter Sellers dr.
Strangelove I meant rube uh Jordan uh
yeah I think I'm going Harrison Ford
killed Gary Oldman he's an accomplished
man Harrison Ford I'm gonna go forward
for takes it you guys Harrison Ford is
the ultimate movie president
yes hail to the chief oh boy that was
fun and patriotic dog gone it I want to
thank my awesome panel James Adomian
Jordan Morris and Trevor Moore check out
their links in section below also got to
give shout out to cinema now from Best
Buy for sponsoring this week's episode
and because they're sponsoring this
week's episode we've got a sweet 25
dollar Best Buy gift card to give away
how can you win that you ask tell us who
your ultimate presidential ticket would
be of pop culture characters Walter
White and Jesse tyrion lanister and
Batman Liz Lemon and honey boo boo best
answer you get a $25 Best Buy gift card
that's how we roll I want to thank you
for watching screen junkies I'm Hal
Rudnick bye-bye